gafford's second-round picks this year
by the great feed and the alley-oop slam
dunk from gaffer made two players you
get two to play what do you got to do
you got a fine meal per man Kobe white
effort on the near turnover gets it to
white show Kobe's range just inside the
arc
Isaac Bongo just got traded to
Washington to try to create the cap
space for Kawhi Leonard they've had a
number of guys johnathan women's leather
two-way players what's the catch side of
the backboards it comes out to the
Lakers and half note Bulls come away
with it here's Makoto nice though look
to Kobe white game the second half
Hutchison stationed in the right corner
right now Kobe white found open from 17
feet away and tradesmen left this
rebound in the basketball so we get so
seduced by his ability to get to the rim
and make those type of plays shooting
nights for Jordan Howard on Monday this
year had a really good year shooting a
deep to that time for Kobe why he has
six rebounds as well here in his summer
league debut
and now as Chicago steel white on a four
on one for the
guy flashing his speed once again from
end to end
Chicago's lead to all of a sudden back
up to 14 and this is how they did it
late in the first quarter turning over
the Lakers it's converting on the other
end first game I mean look this guy's
become ball screens defending the
basketball getting others involved shots
going to be made he's a good enough
shooter he's gonna make shots players
some of them from that LeBron James 0
that is still under contract but trying
to rebuild through it as Kobe white
scores on the layup
get a chance to see the ball go away and
attack the basket use your quickness
play downhill and now you can hit this
pull-up jumper there you go Toby
Whiteman full-on game Chicago just like
that back within for the Bulls
who have done their damage from
three-point land four of five nice and
step back on the baseline make her play
up and come off that ball screen create
a little space there's a little Dirk
Nowitzki step one leg to one leg with a
one leg off the left leg 32 games last
year in the jeely Salt Lake City stars
nice answer on the other end from over
and then if I do I hope to have a third
of the energy Batman a 7% shooting for
the Cavaliers 43% for the Bulls Wyatt
able to get it by the extended arm of
Barclays Golden Tate in the first round
of the NBA draft you can check out more
of Kevin's Horta juniors journey on
declared streaming exclusively on ESPN
Plus
this happy start make a couple baskets
because our great pretty generic on she
would have said you know nothing about
basketball why did we open up with him
it's amazing us he's got really good
feet defensively he covers ground is
he's active he can get out on ball
screens to get back and plays it just he
doesn't have great lift is long who has
21 points and eight assists today you
know so quietly putting together an
outstanding summer league has me through
long as the Bulls get another basket
from Atoka we've taken a 12 to lead here
early on white over Williams nice play
stems the time pelicans get it right
back none does I know what's good you
know the numbers have probably changed
but as of a couple of seasons ago tried
to make the right play there's no way he
was gonna block that right would have
been upset if he wouldn't have came one
a thousand times a night on top that
will will be and that is unfortunate so
if he ever has anybody ever doubt that
he played in the hell in Las Vegas
summer league white pushes for Chicago
he'll do it himself
back-to-back race for Kobe white the
rookie has the feeling sub this is the
one before early in the game he tried to
force Ted get to the basket turn the
ball over there didn't have anybody
running with him Kobe white behind the
back
that's what you want to see hangs it hit
the different caches in with the three
rookies showing their stuff all over the
place here at Thomas and Mack 21 now for
the rookie 2q Alexander Walker the
Canadian from Virginia Tech finish my
white that'll be a delay of game penalty
or a technical foul perhaps Alexander
Walker and Hayes have been tracking each
other in terms of points they're both at
23 against you know what it looks like
to me without les dije noticing that
word like he's free down it's like he
was just like he was caved in college
and now getting to the NBA he's free to
express themselves and play the type of
game he's always wanted over his role
absolutely that's what he's done to that
pass here every time does stop mister
play do you look at the coach gaffer
came over with deep flyswatter and
adjusted that shot here's Kobe white on
a catch and shoot and it's good and it's
not always kind Carlesimo you know Don
Newman these are great coaches very
high-level coaches and all of them I've
learned from which moves shocked you the
most in this free agency oh that's a
good one
you know I did see the Paul George thing
I go way back from when I was an
assistant coach Caron Butler is not just
a terrific player as you know rich he's
a better human being he's an excellent
father you have a ton of things to be
excited about for the future in Chicago
done a 4 on the shot clock you copy
white got it off this guy it's good
[Applause]
let's pass into the corner by Michael
Boulder he changed years on that curl
[Music]
who's Simon these lines right that baby
clearly right over bridges got it back
they'll post up against Kobe white nice
knocked away by white much' sent off to
Kobe right live drive
it's amazing how rewarded when they're
posing in when you do something great on
the defensive end of the floor
oh that the Bulls coaching staff is they
want to see some improvement in that
area corner three it's good off the pass
from Kobe white Michael Boulder drops it
into a terrific rebound
[Music]
Kobe white kicks it out to macaca for
three and back from the Bulls with a
chance to tie some speed of Kobe white
lazing a corner three is good and we are
tied Mychal Mulder off the great feed
from Kobe white 1001 said that is the
most sort of pulsating of a venue that
they have been asked that's the closest
thing I've seen to it was the bus around
every game and I think he's gonna be a
hard worker he's gonna continue to trend
in the right direction exciting player
to watch in the future
Kobe white with one on the shot clock
hits each a gaffer who puts it in and
the Bulls take the lead pulling it out
down to five on the shot clock and now
he will make his move into the paint
ball what a tape by Kobe white and a
chance for three found the opportunity
got it to the seams of the defense able
to get to the paint and finish with the
contact with the offhand fella
Jeremiah Hill for the Bulls does Kobe
white need to probe more downhill it's
like he's getting you don't and here we
go Kobe white as he does probe and he
took the bump so a chance for three look
he's gonna size him up turn the corner
you probably read it right read his mind
you've got to get something easy what's
up you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content